[Musique]
au seuil de leur vie son frère et ses
soeurs sont donc parvenus à leur fin
Albert Lévy repose donc désormais en
France lui qui était mort pour la France
libre durant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et que l'armée française avait enterré
dans sa ville d'origine à Oran mais que
nous raconte au juste l'histoire de
cette famille juive venue d'Algérie et
décrite dans ce documentaire réalisé par
Michael zoumstein et en quoi ces romans
familiaux aux allures toutes simples
peuvent-ils contribuer au travail
mémoriel en cours entre la France et
l'Algérie ce sont les questions que nous
allons maintenant poser à nos deux
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc en commençant par vous Benjamin
storat bienvenue c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous recevoir dans cette
émission vous êtes historien spécialiste
de l'histoire du Maghreb de l'Algérie et
particulièrement de la guerre d'Algérie
vous êtes l'auteur du rapport sur les
questions mémorielles portant sur la
colonisation et la guerre d'Algérie que
vous avez commandité Emmanuel Macron en
juillet 2020 ce rapport vous l'avez
remis 6 mois plus tard au chef de l'État
et il a été publié chez Albin Michel
sous le titre France Algérie les
passions douloureuses et puis au
chapitre de vos ouvrages on citera aussi
histoire dessinée des Juifs d'Algérie de
l'Antiquité à nos jours il est en lien
avec notre émission d'aujourd'hui et
disponible aux éditions La Découverte
également avec nous Agnès Aziza
bienvenue à vous vous êtes scénariste et
directrice d'écriture pour la télévision
vous êtes également écrivaine pour la
jeunesse et vous avez été forces de
proposition dans le cadre de la
commission mémoire et vérité France
Algérie commission qui avait d'ailleurs
été préconisé par Benjamin storat dans
son rapport remis à Emmanuel Macron vos
propositions ont concerné les cimetières
algériens on va bien sûr y revenir dans
cette émission et vous êtes par ailleurs
membre de l'Association des Amis des
cimetières de Saint-Eugène bollorine à
Alger
peut-être pour qu'on comprenne bien le
documentaire que nous venons de voir
nous sommes dans quel type de famille
avec ce documentaire c'est une famille
qui est très représentative en fait des
Juifs d'Algérie notamment ce dos d'Oran
c'est-à-dire des familles pleinement
intégrées à la société française les
Juifs d'Algérie avaient été fait
français depuis le décret crémeux de
1870 donc là ça faisait 5 6 générations
qu'ils étaient français donc ils sont
par conséquent tellement quelquefois
intégrés j'allais dire assimilé à la
culture française qui se sont même
quelque part c'est dit dans le film
éloigné des pratiques de la religion
juive c'est dit tout à fait au démarrage
je sais pas si absolument vous souvenez
mes usages et nous etc et donc il y a ce
facteur puissant de l'assimilation
culturelle et politique qui joue et cet
amour de la France bien sûr qui qui se
marre qui se concrétise et qu'on voit
dans ce film sur le fait de vouloir
rapatrier en France ce corps d'un
militaire mort au combat en 1944 et non
pas pendant la guerre d'Algérie donc par
conséquent c'est assez représentatif
d'Oran d'Alger mais pas forcément de
l'ensemble des Juifs d'Algérie par
exemple à Constantine ma ville qui est
votre ville d'origine tout à fait
c'était pas tout à fait ça la tradition
religieuse était très forte la pratique
de la langue arabe ne s'était jamais
éteinte dans cette ville de consensus
une ville de l'intérieur ce qui était
pas le cas d'Alger d'Oran et il y avait
aussi d'autres petits endroits entre
guillemets disséminés dans toute
l'Algérie dans les Aurès en Kabylie ou
ailleurs ou les traditions les pratiques
religieuses c'était quand même encore
Viva c'était encore développé donc c'est
à la fois très représentatif de ce qu'on
était les Juifs d'Algérie dans des
grandes villes où ce qu'on appelait les
Européens étaient majoritaires comme
Alger Oran donc c'est très représentatif
et en même temps ça ne dit pas toute
l'histoire bien sûr de ces Juifs
d'Algérie qui est un petit peu plus
compliqué puisque comme on le sait les
Juifs d'Algérie étaient présents dans ce
pays bien avant
de la présence française des siècles et
des siècles avant la présence française
donc l'histoire qu'ils avaient eux-mêmes
étaient une histoire de longue durée
avec la terre algérienne nous sommes
dans une famille piednoire et est-ce
qu'on peut préciser ce qui n'est pas
précisé dans ce film mais qui m'a été
précisé par l'un des fils d'une sœur
d'Albert qui est le réalisateur de ce
film c'est que sa mère et donc
ces deux sœurs et
ce frère qu'on voit dans ce film on
quitté Oran au tout début des années 50
pour revenir en France et leur père est
resté lui à Orange jusqu'en
1961 là on est sur un cas de figure très
spécifique une histoire très singulière
avec ce film concernant cette famille
pied-noir qui décide de rapatrier un
cercueil de Puy Oran celui de leur frère
mort pour la France en 44 c'est très
spécifique cette histoire oui c'est très
spécifique il y a deux spécificités
nulle part c'est un militaire donc
il était enterré à Oran mais au
cimetière de petit lacs qui est le
cimetière militaire français en Algérie
et c'était un mort pour la France donc
il a ce statut là qui fait que la France
est tenue d'entretenir ces sépultures
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle des
sépultures perpétuelles et donc c'est à
l'État français d'entretenir ses épaules
donc ça déjà c'est une spécificité de
en fait il y a une triple spécificité
parce que dans le documentaire ils
expliquent que en fait il a été inhumé
en Italie puis rapatrier en Algérie et
inhumé à petit lac donc là déjà ça veut
dire que il n'a pas été restitué à la
famille il a été enterré dans un
cimetière militaire donc il y a une
chose à
sinon cette fameuse bataille oui des CD
Albert en 44 ensuite il a été enterré à
Naples puis au Rangers
soient inhumés et soit resté enfin
retourne en Algérie en fait j'aurais
bien voulu savoir le comment du pourquoi
en fait donc dans ce qu'il a été enterré
dans un cimetière militaire français que
leur rapatriement de son corps a été
possible même si ça a été long
ça a duré 6 mois on ne connaît pas
d'ailleurs au passage le coût de cette
opération et on ne sait pas qui paye en
fait est-ce que c'est la famille ou
est-ce que c'est l'Office national des
anciens combattants et victimes de
guerre qui a pris en charge
le rapatriement et les frais de
rapatriement ça c'est pas dit en fait
alors Benjamin storat c'est vrai que
quand on s'interroge sur les familles
qui peuvent être confrontées à ce type
de situation évidemment les Pieds-Noirs
il peut y avoir aussi les familles
de soldats français mort pendant la
guerre d'Algérie et puis bien sûr les
familles de harki est-ce que voilà ce
sont les trois grandes familles
finalement de cette histoire qui peuvent
être confrontés ou sollicité ce type de
demande de rapatriement de corps mais
est-ce possible et entre la France et
l'Algérie aujourd'hui il y a quelles
conditions oui vous êtes dans vous avez
bien fait l'identifier les différentes
populations concernées par cette
histoire bon la plus importante bien sûr
ce sont les rapatriés d'Algérie les
Européens d'Algérie dont font partie les
Juifs d'Algérie bien sûr qui sont des
Français d'Algérie bien entendu et il y
a effectivement ce qui vient d'être dit
par Agnès Aziza la responsabilité des
États respectives dans la gestion dans
l'entretien des cimetières on y
reviendra peut-être c'est quelque chose
d'assez compliqué et donc il demande
beaucoup de temps beaucoup d'énergie
elle est bien placée pour le savoir sur
la question de l'entretien des
cimetières c'est un sujet très important
j'en ai parlé dans mon rapport vous avez
fait à cet endroit voilà le président de
la République parce que dans le fond la
question du travail de deuil sur la fin
de l'Algérie française passe aussi par
des questions très simples et matériels
qui sont la question des entretiens ou
pas des cimetières alors c'est plus
cette question d'ailleurs de l'entretien
des cimetières et de leur préservation
que celle de l'ecubation et du transfert
des corps qui est très minoritaire qui
est une pratique très très minoritaire
on reviendra d'ailleurs sur cette
interrogation sur pourquoi la pratique
est si minoritaire c'est-à-dire
l'exhumation et le transfert des corps
c'est un peu moins vrai maintenant pour
les Juifs d'Algérie bon certains
réclament disons le transfert de corps
en d'Israël non mais ça c'est une
question qu'on peut peut-être si on a le
temps d'abord
sur le plan religieux
comment dirais on peut s'interroger sur
sur cette faible pourcentage
disons de demandes de transfert de
passage des corps d'une rive à l'autre
de la Méditerranée alors il y a
plusieurs interprétations possibles soit
il y a comme interprétation comme
hypothèse le fait dans le fond qu'on ne
veut pas se séparer d'eux donc on veut
pas se séparer de cette histoire
algérienne on veut pas se séparer de
l'histoire qui était celle de la France
en Algérie il y a une volonté de non
séparation c'est une histoire qui se
poursuit quelque part avec le fait de
laisser des corps reposés en
terre-natales c'est une première si une
première hypothèse à mon avis c'est la
plus importante mais il y a une deuxième
hypothèse c'est celle d'effacer celle de
l'effacement dans sa mémoire de disons
ce qui pourrait faire se rappeler en
disons comme une sorte de traumatisme le
fait d'avoir été obligé quelque part de
quitter l'Algérie il y a aussi la
question de l'effacement de dans la
mémoire et donc le retour dans cette
mémoire de ce qui a été déjà effacé mais
là on rentre déjà dans une autre dans un
autre type de discussion mais cette
question disons de l'entretien à mon
avis et plus importante que celle de
l'exhumation et du passage du transfert
disons d'une RIB à l'autre de la
Méditerranée alors vous avez fait un
certain nombre de propositions je l'ai
dit en vous présentant concernant cette
question précise des cimetières
l'entretien des cimetières semble
effectivement centrale mais à quel coût
comment et puis il s'agit de faire un
inventaire précis avant toute chose
c'est ce que vous vous avez préconisé
oui parce que en fait donc il y a
plusieurs questions par rapport au
cimetière
il y a la question de l'entretien
pourquoi pourquoi on continuerait pas
entretenir ces tombes parce que ce sont
quand même des Français qui sont inhumés
là-bas donc c'est un vrai souci il y a
aussi la question du regroupement c'est
à dire qu'il y a des cimetières qui sont
très très abîmés et donc les familles
représentées par les associations
demandent à ce que les les
corps soient regroupés dans des
ossuaires dans des cimetières plus
grands et puis il y a une dimension qui
moi me saute aux yeux chaque fois que je
vais en Algérie c'est la dimension
patrimoniale ce sont des cimetières qui
sont mais quand on aime larf funéraire
qui sont sublimes c'est des mini perles
à chaise partout c'est Oran et réputé
pour être le Père Lachaise de la
Méditerranée sainte-eugène à Alger c'est
la même chose et je pense qu'à constante
non pas du tout c'est parce que à cette
époque là 19e 20e siècle la tombe la
sépulture et importante et donc on y met
l'argent nécessaire
la chaise c'est avec des tons mais d'une
d'un travail de sculpture incroyable des
émaux de fin c'est très très beau et
c'est quel dommage de voir ce patrimoine
commun tombé en ruine quoi c'est moi
j'ai l'impression qu'il faut passer 10 à
15 ans en fait il faut tenir pendant 10
à 15 ans pour que
les personnes aussi bien en Algérie
qu'en France se rendent compte de ce
patrimoine funéraire incroyable parce
que ça a conservé c'est ça peut être des
lieux de tourisme incroyables
j'ai lu que la France entre 2005 et 2018
avec consacré 1,8 millions d'euros et
entretiens des cimetières ça concernait
d'ailleurs 314 cimetières les choses
sont très précises et que ce budget
aurait été divisé de deux tiers depuis
2018 c'est vrai oui en fait
on laisse tomber ces cimetières du côté
français
c'est tellement compliqué et tellement
complexe aussi bien les questions
d'entretien que de regroupement et que
pour l'instant oui c'est un peu la
patate chaude mais c'est une patate
chaude qui date de
l'indépendance parce que en fait on a eu
l'impression que c'est Jacques Chirac en
2003 qui a mis en place un plan ce qu'on
a appelé le plan Chirac de regroupements
d'entretiens mais 20 ans plus tôt les
socialistes ont travaillé sur la
question et depuis 63 je crois les
premiers textes que j'ai trouvé c'est 63
ou il est question justement de des
sépultures civiles qu'est-ce qu'on fait
comment s'organise donc c'est présent
depuis depuis l'indépendance en fait et
vous dites entre autorité française et
autorité algérienne
parce que les cimetières tels qu'ils
avaient été conçus par la France par
exemple au 19e 20e siècle était
légèrement à l'extérieur des villes un
peu comme en France un peu comme partout
ailleurs mais avec le développement
urbain le développement démographique en
Algérie beaucoup de ces cimetières vous
avez cité le chiffre de plus de 300
cimetières c'est considérable c'est
colossal faut pas oublier que l'Algérie
c'était la France des départements
français donc bien évidemment les
cimetières dans ce cadre là je vois un
rôle très très important comme lieu du
souvenir pour les populations
européennes juives etc c'était très ce
sont des lieux du souvenir
naturellement s'exerce toute une série
de cérémonies du souvenir c'est très
important or ces cimetières qui étaient
situés au périphérie sont devenus des
lieux presque situés au coeur des villes
algériennes parce qu'évidemment
l'Algérie est passé de 9 millions 10
millions d'habitants en 62 63
aujourd'hui à plus de 40 millions
d'habitants moi par exemple j'avais été
dans la famille de ma de mon père à
frenchela dans les ores parce que c'est
le berceau de ma famille et les gens
m'avaient amené au cimetière pour voir
des tombes de la femme historra de cache
là et en fait c'était au coeur de la
ville c'est à dire que c'était pas du
tout des cimetières en bordure ou à
l'extérieur etc et ça pose un problème
pour les autorités algériennes bien
entendu de se retrouver confronté à
l'existence de lieux très important
parce qu'il faut respecter les morts
c'est ça fait partie aussi de la
tradition algérienne bien sûr de respect
des morts et ben comment respecter les
morts lorsqu'on se retrouve face à des
espaces qui envahissent l'espace public
au sens large c'est pas simple et donc
il faudrait qu'il y ait effectivement
une prise de responsabilité de l'État de
l'État français en particulier pour
savoir ce qu'ils doivent faire par
rapport à ça alors il y a eu des
propositions de regroupement des
ossuaires etc bon ça a été refusé par la
part beaucoup de familles ça a été ça a
été très difficile de mettre en œuvre il
y a aussi le fait que peu de moyens ont
été développés ça c'est encore une autre
question c'est les moyens
matériels financiers etc donc il y a des
revendications d'associations qui
demandent plus de moyens etc mais le
fait t c'est lorsque j'ai fait ce
rapport et que j'ai mentionné ces
préconisations sur les cimetières il y a
beaucoup de gens qui étaient très
surpris en disant mais 60 ans après
l'indépendance 60 ans après
l'indépendance comment faire un travail
de deuil d'une histoire comme celle-là
qui est énorme sans traiter de la
question
de la mémoire à travers la question des
cimetières et les gens étaient très
étonnés je veux dire que beaucoup de
parmi toutes les préconisations que j'ai
faites c'était celle qui avait suscité
le plus d'étonnement c'est à dire que
dans le fond personne ne s'était posé la
question de savoir quel était le devenir
de 300 cimetières en Algérie ou reposer
la mémoire de la France en Algérie parce
que c'est là qu'elle repose cette
mémoire alors on va revenir bien sûr sur
cette fausse mémorielle que dégage aussi
ce documentaire je voulais juste revenir
sur le cas spécifique des harkis
80000 personnes sont revenues en France
donc en 62
les harkis aujourd'hui ont aussi des
cimetières concernant leur leurs aïeux
j'imagine en Algérie peuvent-ils espérer
voir rapatrier les cordes de leurs aïeux
en France les harkis aujourd'hui
là c'est encore un sujet complexe
dans l'absolu oui ça serait possible
mais après c'est dans quel état sont les
cimetières
parce qu'en fait il y a une
problématique de cimetière militaire qui
ont été entretenues etc aussi bien
cimetière juif musulman que chrétiens
il y a un déficit d'entretien des
cimetières en Algérie en fait donc après
c'est comment comment retrouver la tombe
enfin est-ce qu'elle est est-ce qu'on
peut la retrouver est-ce qu'elle est
accessible et est-ce que c'est possible
d'inhumer mais en général dans la
religion musulmane on exhume pas en fait
il y a aussi des contraintes religieuses
qui font que il y a des en fait il faut
des conditions extraordinaires pour
aussi bien dans la religion juive que
dans la religion musulmane donc dans la
religion juive la seule exhumation
possible qui suggéré dans le film c'est
lorsque le corps va en Israël mais vers
la France
dans les années
1910-1920 par exemple dans le cimetière
de Saint-Eugène il y a des ossuaires
alors que ces proscrits par la religion
juive mais par manque de place en fait
ils ont exhumé pour mettre dans des
ossuaires donc on s'arrange toujours
aussi quoi c'est votre rapport Benjamin
Stora
vous vous engagez en faveur de la
facilitation des déplacements des harkis
entre les deux les Doris bien entendu
autrement dit une famille
harki aujourd'hui en France elle est
pire difficultés pour aller voir ses
aïeux enterrés en Algérie c'était le cas
après l'indépendance récemment après
dans les années 60-70 c'est beaucoup
moins le cas aujourd'hui beaucoup moins
le cas aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il y
a une plus grande facilité disons de
déplacement de ceux qui meurent en
France pour aller être enterré en
Algérie il y a les cas sont beaucoup
plus rares disons d'obstacles etc s'il y
a des obstacles disons-le franchement
c'est d'abord d'ordre administratif
bureaucratique et d'ordre financier
parce que ça coûte cher tout simplement
je veux dire de se faire enterrer en
Algérie ça coûte très cher et donc il y
a aussi des obstacles financiers qui
font que les gens vont aller vont rester
disons enterrer en France donc les
choses ont changé à ce niveau-là il y a
quand même c'est pas tout c'est pas
toujours la même chose quoi il y a pas
une sorte de continuité disons dans les
pratiques il y a un arrangement dans les
pratiques qui font que dans le fond face
à la mort il y a cette sorte de
réconciliation quoi je veux dire qui
existe c'est à dire que de ceux qui ont
et qui veulent disons être enterrés en
Algérie quelque part il manifeste aussi
un attachement et donc à partir de là
bah les autorités algériennes laissent
faire bien entendu et il y a beaucoup de
gens qui sont enterré en Algérie comme
les immigrés comme les immigrés
algériens je veux dire en France là
aussi ici beaucoup se font enterrer en
France et aussi et peu enfin moins en
moins plutôt en Algérie c'est aussi pour
des questions qui qui tiennent à
l'économie parce que beaucoup de très
cher aussi bien entendu et puis c'est le
fait que avec l'installation des
familles en France et bien ce qu'on
appelle l'intégration c'est aussi le
fait de se faire enterrer en France pour
les familles de harkis c'est pareil de
moins en moins de gens veulent se faire
enterrer en Algérie et pour les Juifs
d'Algérie il y a un seul exemple à ma
connaissance une seule personne qui a
demandé à retourner se reposer entre
guillemets dans sa terre natale c'est
Roger Hanin c'est Roger Hana a demandé à
être enterré en Algérie d'ailleurs il
était disons son enterrement a été
l'occasion de d'une grande cérémonie
organisée par les autorités jeunes mais
fait partie de ces cas très rares de
personnes qui vit qui veulent disons se
faire enterrer en Algérie on va écouter
un extrait du documentaire c'est Roger
qui nous explique pourquoi il a souhaité
voir rapatrier le cercueil et le corps
de son frère
quand même
l'avenir il est là avec le toute la
famille le court-métra
autrement il était isolé le sol pauvre
dans un cimetière militaire il voulait
ça mais pas la solitude éternelle non
c'est l'accompagnement éternel Roger et
décédé quelques semaines seulement après
avoir réussi avec ses sœurs un rapatrier
ce cercueil en France on parlait de la
force que peut représenter ce type de
démarche pour réconcilier les deux clubs
pour un travail mémoriel justement
est-ce que vous-même à titre personnel
vous avez été amené à retrouver des
aïeux du côté algérien
moi toute ma famille est de d'Algérie en
fait de on rentre lemsen et Alger depuis
des générations parce que ce sont des
Juifs d'Algérie et oui oui j'ai fait
j'ai fait ce travail là notamment en
2019 où là j'ai vraiment fait
des recherches pour retrouver toutes les
maisons où ils avaient vécu dans les
différentes villes et puis aussi aller
sur les tombes et les retrouver nettoyer
les tombes et voilà oui ça m'a paru
enfin j'ai mis du temps mais ça m'a paru
évident de faire ça parce que vous-même
vous êtes né en France à niche je n'ai
pas précisé c'était en 68
et donc vous étiez de la première
génération qui est arrivé en France
absolument et pendant des années
pourquoi autant de temps parce que
j'avais en fait moi quand j'étais petite
l'Algérie ça a toujours fait partie de
mon quotidien il y avait la boîte à
chaussures avec les photos de l'Algérie
et je demandais toujours à ma grand-mère
et là c'est où et là c'est comment et
comment c'était enfin donc j'ai grandi
avec l'Algérie mais je m'étais fait une
image de ce pays là et j'ai mis beaucoup
de temps avant de
de casser cette imaginaire pour aller
voir la réalité en fait j'avais peur de
l'émotion qu'elle a aimé teindre et
c'était drôle parce que autant sur place
j'ai été comme un poisson dans l'eau et
super heureuse et joyeuse et tout et
autant avant quand je
un an avant que je dise j'ai envie
d'aller en Algérie et je vais en Algérie
je pleurais à chaque fois je n'arrivais
pas à dire je pars en Algérie où j'ai
envie d'aller en Algérie c'était je
m'effondrais donc je m'étais dit mais ça
va être horrible j'ai pleuré partout
tout le temps et en fait non non c'était
juste je
l'incroyable sensation de rentrer chez
moi vous êtes retourné à plusieurs
reprises et pendant des durées assez
longues hein plus de 30 jours Benjamin
storat peut-être que ceux qui nous
regardent le savent pas mais vous-même
vous avez recherché la tombe d'un
grand-père à Constantine je crois vous
en avez même fait un documentaire 2012
oui tout à fait cette démarche il y a eu
deux documentaires d'abord un avec ma
mère en 91 cimetière juive de
Constantine où elle va chercher la tombe
de son père et elle va avoir beaucoup de
mal à retrouver la tombe de son père
alors qu'elle avait l'habitude
naturellement d'aller au cimetière
régulièrement et ben c'est un petit peu
la même mésaventure qui m'était arrivé
avant lorsque j'ai annoncé à mon père
qui était encore vivant que j'allais
partir pour la première fois en Algérie
83 la première chose qu'il m'a dit c'est
il faut que tu ailles voir la tombe de
mon père c'était ça sa première
revendication et il m'a fait tout un
plan du cimetière juif de Constantine
qui est très grand parce que c'est un
cimetière ou sur enterré des gens comme
Raymond le musicien etc enfin bon c'est
un grand cimetière très beau d'ailleurs
magnifique sur les hauteurs de la ville
de Constantine qui domine toute la ville
donc il m'a fait un plan il m'a dit tu
vois tu rentres et puis tu tournes à
gauche tu remontes l'allée etc je dis
tout le temps fais pas papa il y a pas
de problème je vais trouver la tempe de
mon grand-père c'était mon grand-père
qui est mort en 45 je suis arrivé dans
ce cimetière
et j'ai pas retrouvé la tombe de mon
grand-père la première fois je parle en
83 j'ai cherché chercher tourner revenu
je l'ai pas trouvé je savais pas disons
où était cette tombe c'est
extraordinaire c'est comme si ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure comme si
quelque part j'avais cette ce désir
inconscient de ne pas fixer l'histoire
dans la dans la mort en fait et dans le
départ définitive dans les loisignement
définitif il y avait cette volonté de ne
pas accepter l'éloignement définitif qui
fait que je n'acceptais pas de voir ce
qui était en face de moi c'est-à-dire la
tombe de mon grand-père c'était que plus
tard que je l'ai retrouvé bien sûr quand
je suis retourné parce que je suis
retourné souvent en Algérie et mon père
était déjà mort mais je n'ai pas osé lui
dire quand je suis retourné le voir je
n'ai pas osé lui dire parce que la
première question qui m'a posé à mon
retour d'Algérie en 83 c'est alors tu as
vu la tombe de mon père je l'ai regardé
j'ai réfléchi je lui ai dit oui bien sûr
que je l'ai revu j'ai pas osé lui faire
de la peine et ça l'a soulagé mon père
et moi un an après pourquoi est-ce qu'on
ce besoin de retourner en Algérie
qu'est-ce que ça peut apporter à la à la
réflexion et Dieu sait si elle est
importante et on l'a vu avec le rapport
de Benjamin Stora à la réflexion
mémorielle entre entre les deux pays
aujourd'hui
à votre avis qu'est-ce qui fait sens
c'est tellement évident pour moi que
j'ai du mal à en parler en fait je pense
que ça apporte un certain apaisement ça
permet de
rendre compte que c'est possible parce
qu'en fait ce qui m'a beaucoup surpris
c'est que chaque fois que j'ai dit que
j'allais en Algérie ou que j'étais allée
en Algérie à des pieds-noirs leurs
réaction ça a été dire ah bon c'est
possible mais tu n'as pas été en danger
c'était pas ben non
et puis on est on est comme chez soi et
ce qui est incroyable c'est que les gens
vous disent bienvenue chez vous donc ça
fait du bien
et
[Musique]
en fait
je trouve que c'est essentiel de de
connaître ses racines pour pouvoir
avancer et puis et transmettre c'est
documentaire aussi c'est que ce n'est
que des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années après que qu'ils entamment
cette démarche pourquoi autant de temps
et quand on parle à des pieds-noirs
certains d'entre eux ne veulent jamais
revenir en Algérie puis d'autres font
cette démarche mais très longtemps après
aussi il y a une occultation au monde
qui a été réelle de l'Algérie oublier
l'Algérie après l'indépendance de 62
c'est clair pour pour beaucoup de
repères d'Algérie il y avait d'abord la
volonté de vivre de survivre c'est à
dire de tout simplement trouver un
logement et trouver un travail je dirais
encore une fois je reviens aux questions
économiques mais oui il fallait tout
simplement dans les années 70
il y avait rien du tout nous on a vécu
dans un petit pavillon à 30 à Montreuil
dans l'année 62 et ensuite dans une de
garage des infectés pendant deux ans bon
ensuite on a eu le HLM à Sartrouville
enfin parcours classique dans le fond
des immigrés ou des réfugiés dans le
fond mais sans être des réfugiés
puisqu'on était français donc c'est ça
l'ambiguïté le paradoxe mais en fait
dans les années 60-70 enfin de ce que
moi je garde comme souvenir y compris
comme adolescent ben c'était le fait
qu'il fallait avancer pour vivre et ne
pas trop se souvenir de l'Algérie parce
que sinon ce souvenir sans arrêt de
cette de ce qui s'était passé quelque
part freiner la possibilité de pouvoir
construire une vie il fallait construire
sa vie et après bien sûr dans les années
80-90 notamment après les années 90 il y
a eu ce retour de mémoire qui a commencé
à s'exercer mais le drame le problème
c'est que dans les années 90 il y a eu
ce qu'on appelle la décennie sanglante
sur la question des islamistes et donc
ceux qui voulaient revenir on peut
l'appeler comme ça qui voulait revenir
en Algérie dans les années 90 bah non
pas pu d'où la question que soulevait
Agnès Aziza lorsqu'elle disait qu'elle
revenait en Algérie qui avait en fait le
souvenir disons de cette terrible
décennie sanglante c'est-à-dire de cette
peur etc donc il y a eu ce freinage
aussi alors il y a eu cette volonté dans
les années 2000 avec Jacques Chirac de
faire ce traité d'amitié qui a permis
disons qu'on retrouve une sorte d'espoir
disons de réalisation mémorielle et qui
ne sait pas concrétiser et on est encore
dans cet entre deux on est encore disons
dans cette complexité des rapports de
méfiance de soupçons réciproque qui fait
que c'est très difficile de d'avancer
réellement quoi sur cette question
disons de travail mémoriel vous faites
le même constat on en parlera autour de
vous
avec certains de vos aïeux peut-être de
gens plus jeunes aujourd'hui vous pouvez
côtoyer oui et en fait ce qui me fait
plaisir c'est de voir que la génération
des 20 30 ans
s'intéresse à l'Algérie ce qui sont des
descendants de rapatrier ils ont un
intérêt certain pour pour l'Algérie avec
une envie d'y aller et donc ça donc ça
ça fait plaisir en fait certains sont
encore complètement braqués et c'est
les positions des parents et des
grands-parents anti indépendants qui se
qui se transmettent en fait les parcours
se transmettent donc
mais quand même il y a je trouve qu'il y
a un courant qui est qui est très
positif et qui donne espoir pour une
suite de réconciliation et puis je
voulais vous poser une question parce
que vous êtes je l'ai dit un membre de
l'Association des Amis des cimetières de
saint-ogène bollorine à Alger qu'est-ce
qui vous a amené à être membre de cette
association précisément pourquoi cette
passion pour les cimetières algérien
tellement bien en fait je suis tombé
amoureuse de cimetière donc je j'y suis
allé je l'ai trouvé sublime en même
temps c'est un cimetière enfin c'est un
double cimetière de 13 hectares un côté
chrétien un côté juif qui est sur une
colline donc en terrasse avec tout en
haut Notre-Dame d'Afrique et la mer en
face c'est mes mais moi je Roger Hanin
et donc enterré dans ce cimetière là
parce que bien de nous rappeler voilà
c'est c'est là où je dois être inhumé
c'est trop beau c'est avoir la mer en
face c'est là que vous demanderez ah bah
si je peux oui mais moi je voudrais même
avoir la nationalité algérienne donc
tout est parti de d'un côté de mes j'y
ai droit je le vois pas pourquoi je
n'aurais pas la nationalité algérienne
mais il y a pas que les Européens
d'Algérie qui ont cette espèce de
nostalgie voir ce désir d'être enterré
cette semaine j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
qui est appelé l'Algérie qui était à
Constantine en 61 qui a 84 ans qui
m'avait écrit je l'ai rencontré
et il m'a dit il était à Philippe villas
Skikda avec la plage de Stora et il m'a
dit moi mon désir c'est si je meurs je
suis avec mes cendres soient dispersés
au large de Philippeville il a la
semaine dernière c'est pas un truc
ancien et j'étais très surprise c'était
un appel d'Algérie et il m'a dit je sais
pas ce qu'on est allé faire là-bas il a
été blessé en Algérie il était revenu
meurtri de cette histoire donc le
silence donc l'occultation donc la
volonté de vivre et arriver à la fin de
sa vie voilà ce qu'il m'a dit moi si je
meurs je veux que mes cendres soient
dispersés au large d'Alger de
Philippeville fin de Skikda c'est
extraordinaire ça sera le mot de la fin
un grand merci vraiment à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission après
ce documentaire il faut ramener Albert
voilà bon on le dédie Albert et on te
dit à Roger son frère qui a réussi à
ramener son frère
à Paris à Bagneux très exactement et qui
nous a malheureusement quitté mais que
nous avons vu dans dans ce film grâce à
l'un des fils de
de la mère de la sœur pardon d'Albert
qui était aussi dans ce documentaire et
c'est lui qui a réalisé ce formidable
film vos réactions ça sera sur HD des
Badoc sur Twitter bien entendu merci
aussi à sel massali qui comme à la
coutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission et puis je vous donne
rendez-vous tout simplement pour un
prochain débat doc avec bien sûr son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]